G. BARNEY ELLISON: I'd like
to see if I can
describe to you how you could
measure the bond energies of
complex molecules.
And to start out, let me just
remind you what
we're talking about.
Let me talk about something like
methane.
I'm going to need a larger
stick.
So if you have methane, and you
want to measure the bond
energy, I literally want to
reach in and measure the
energy it would take to grab
that hydrogen and literally
just rip it out of there.
And when you can see it does
that, the molecule is going to
have a change from a tetrahedral
geometry to a flat geometry.
And there's a potential curve
that I've written as a Morse
oscillator.
And there's a zero point energy,
and you're going to
have to measure the energy to go
from the ground states up
to the dissociation limit.
So I thought I'd try to tell
you, just in a simple way.
If you took a molecule, and
you'd like to try to see if
you could measure the different
bonds in the molecule,
how could the specific bond
energies be measured?
And let me consider something
like methanol.
I'd like to take methanol, and
I'd like to show you how you
measure the bond energy to break
the OH bond, then how
you'd break the CH bond or how
you'd break the CO bond.
And I don't want to calculate
this.
I actually want to measure it.
So one way you can do this is to
use a gas-phase-acidity-
electronegativity cycle.
This is a negative-ion cycle
that you'll take this
molecule, say, methanol, and if
you treat this with a base
such as its fluoride ion, the
fluoride ion is actually going
to attack the methanol.
And when it does this, it's
going to pull a proton off.
And if it does that, you'll form
a methoxide ion.
The fluoride ion will never pull
the proton off the
carbon, because the negative ion
that you get has the
electron sitting on the carbon,
and the oxygen is more
electronegative, so you'll
always get the top ion.
So if you could do that, what
you'd like to think about is,
how can I measure an equilibrium
between these two species?
And if I have the equilibrium, I
can get the enthalpy, and if
I can get the enthalpy, I can
get the acidity of this.
So this is an experiment that a
bunch of us do in Boulder.
The world's expert in these gas
phase acidity measurements
is my colleague Ronnie Bierbaum,
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE Doctor
Veronica Marie Bierbaum.
And she's very good at this.
They have a flow tube, and this
is the experiment you
want to do.
So you would like to measure the
reaction of fluoride ion
pulling a proton off methanol to
get the methoxide ion.
So what you do is...here you
can't get a lecture bottle of
fluoride ion, because they're
charged.
So what you've got to do is take
a gas,
and you make a plasma.
You boil electrons off a
filament.
And as the electrons interact
with the HF, the electrons
get captured into a sigma*
orbital, and the molecule
detonates and gives you an F
minus and hydrogen atoms.
So the fluoride ions are
injected into this flow tube.
And there's methanol in here.
And what happens is, as the
reaction proceeds, the
methanol has a proton removed
from it.
And you're literally watching
the end of the flow tube with
a quadrupole mass spec.
The quadrupole mass spec
monitors the negative ions
that have m/Z 31, and you'll
watch them growing in.
So as you watch the methoxide
ion going in, you can measure
the rate constant K1, that goes
this way.
So if you do that, what you're
after is
the equilibrium constant.
So to get the equilibrium
constant, one way to do this
is that you would measure the
reverse rate.
So if you did that, to measure
such a reaction, now you'd
just turn the reaction...you do
the reverse of this.
You now have to make a vapor of
methoxide anions.
An easy way to do this is to
have electrons interact with
methyl nitrite.
The methyl nitrite then
disintegrates, and it forms
methoxide anion and nitric
oxide, NO
And the methoxide ion then goes
down the flow tube.
And if the methoxide ion
interacts with the HF, now
what you'll see is F minus
growing in.
And you know it's F minus,
because Jesus only made a
finite number of ions that have
m/Z 19,
and fluoride is it.
There's no other.
So it turns out when you do
that, you're
able to monitor this.
So if you've measured K1 and
you've measured K minus 1,
that is going to give you the
equilibrium constant.
And this is the difference in
acidity between
methanol and HF.
But the acidity of HF is
well-known.
It's 370.424 kcal per mole with
this uncertainty.
And so it turns out that these
two numbers give you the
equilibrium constant, and this
is going to give you the gas
phase acidity.
So by making the equilibrium
constant, Professor Bierbaum
has measured the acidity of this
species.
The way to think about this now,
to use acidity, here's
what the gas-phase acidity is.
Remember, she really has this
number in the gas phase.
You know, in the gas phase,
these molecules are never
going to dissociate into ions,
because you've got to
deal with Coulomb's law.
So you're talking about maybe
300, 400 kcal per mole.
So it's a whopping amount of
energy.
So the way to think about this
is, to get that ion, you have
to break the OH bond.
Then you have to somehow measure
the electron affinity.
That gives you the energy of the
negative ion here.
And the ionization energy of a
hydrogen atom is how you
get the proton.
And here, this is the easiest
way I think about this.
This acidity--
you want to get those ions.
The first thing you've got to do
is reach in with a pair of
scissors and cut this bond.
So you've got to pay that
energy.
You've also got to give me the
ionization
energy of hydrogen atom.
You've got to pay me that,
because that
gives you the proton.
And then you take the electron
and put it back on the alkoxy
radical, and that's the electron
affinity.
So it turns out--
Here,
this is what we're after.
We want this bond energy.
And this will be the energy for
that bond only.
And so the electron affinity for
hydrogen atom is known to
some pornographic detail.
You couldn't imagine what's been
done to this poor atom.
This is done to like 80 digits.
So turns out the only thing
you've got to do is now, you
now have to measure the electron
affinity of the radical.
So how are you going to do that?
So this is an experiment that's
done actually here by
Professor Mark Johnson at Yale
University, and it's done a
bit by people in Boulder,
Colorado.
Here's what you do.
You literally take a vapor of
these negative ions.
And if you take a vapor of the
negative ions,
you make a fast beam.
You cross this with a laser.
I know the energy of the laser
precisely.
So what you do is, when the
laser interacts with the
negative ions, you'll eject
electrons, and you catch them
in a hemispherical analyzer.
You literally measure the
kinetic energy.
So this is the kinetic energy.
So here.
This is easy.
If you know what the energy
going in is, and you know what
the energy coming out is, you've
measured those two
things, and the difference is
the binding energy.
So here's the negative ion.
When the electromagnetic wave
comes blazing in and strikes
it, what happens is, here's the
laser energy.
So the molecule literally
interacts with the laser, and
an electron's knocked off, and
what you're going to do, is
you're going to measure the red
arrow.
This is the kinetic energy of
the photoelectron.
So if you measure what comes
out, then the difference is
the binding energy.
So it turns out that this is the
essential experiment you
have to do.
There's a bunch of details
you've got to
pay attention to.
If the product radical is
vibrating, then the
photoelectron kinetic energy
will be smaller than the
measured binding energy.
And these are just a
bunch of words.
Let me just show
you what you do.
This is it.
Jesus, we did this like thirty
years ago.
Christ, I'm an old guy.
When you do this, what you do is
you take a--
right here.
So what you're going to do is,
you're going to measure the
kinetic energy of the electrons
coming out.
So we're making a plot of the
photoelectron kinetic energy.
Here, let me just show, the
laser is 488.
It's a beautiful robin's egg
blue.
Extremely bright laser.
And 488 nanometers is 2.540
electron volts.
So here.
Think about this.
This is the photoelectron
kinetic energy with electrons
coming out.
No electrons can come out with
more than 2.54 eV, because
that's all I've got to put in.
So the first time you see
electronic, counts--
this is electron counts--
is at about 1 eV. When you
actually measure it, it's
measured to be 0.968 eV. And so
the way you get the
electron affinity, is if you put
2.54 eV in, and you
measure 0.968 coming out, then
the difference is 1.572, plus
or minus 4 milli electron volts.
And that's how you do it.
This is detachment to the ground
state
of the methoxy dot.
This is one vibration in the
methoxy dot.
This is two vibrations, this is
three vibrations.
Can you see how cool this is?
You can actually take a
vibrational spectrum.
You're looking at the vibrations
in a radical.
Well, that's not hard--
that's not easy to do.
Because you don't have a lecture
bottle of radicals.
So this is a very powerful
experiment on the one day of
the month when it works.
I'll not kid you.
These experiments of
Professor Bierbaum's,
you spend most of
your time with the hardware,
trying to make sure the
electronics are stable and what
not.
And then when you're running,
these people basically are
dancing around the machine nude
with tambourines, just
trying to keep the machine
stable long
enough to get a spectrum.
But when it works, you're going
to get
a number very clean.
And you see how precise this is?
I mean, this is a very nice
measurement.
So we can now do what we're
going to do.
If Bierbaum has the acidity, and
you know the electron
affinity, and you know the
ionization energy of hydrogen
atom, so here are these numbers.
When you put these things in,
you get out that the bond
energy is about a 105 kcal per
mole.
And this is the bond energy of
methanol in the innergalactic
space with nobody else around.
And all of these people who like
to think they can
calculate everything by using
all these quantum mechanical
programs, now this is the number
they have to get.
There is no place to hide.
This is the cleanly measured
value.
No experimental system is
perfect.
So for example, problems you can
have. I just showed you
how to measure the OH bond.
Suppose you want to measure the
CH bond.
Well, this will never work!
Because the negative cycle will
never work.
Why?
Because when you take any base
that you apply to this, the
base is always going to take off
the most acidic proton.
Well, the most acidic proton is
one off the OH, because you
get the negative on with the
electron on the oxygen.
That's good.
If you have a base that you try
to pull a proton off the
carbon, the electron is going to
be on the carbon atom, and
that's bad.
Oxygen's more electronegative.
It'll hold it much tighter.
So turns out the negative ions
are not going to be a useful
way to do this.
And of course, if you were going
to apply the negative-ion
cycle, then you'd have to
measure the acidity of this
proton, then we'd have to
measure the electron affinity
of this radical.
Does everybody see that this
radical--
this is hydroxy methyl radical--
is different than methoxy?
Because the dot sits on the
carbon, not on the oxygen, so
it's a different radical.
So if you can't make the ion,
then we can't do our
measurements, and we're dead.
Not to worry.
There's other techniques you can
do.
My friend David Gutman does
radical kinetics.
And so a thing you can do is you
can make chlorine atoms.
And when you make chlorine atoms
in a flow tube, he uses
photoionization mass spec to
monitor the products.
And so he can measure K1, and he
can measure K minus 1.
So he gets to equal--
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Can you
explain what a flow tube is?
PROFESSOR ELLISON: A flow tube
is a beautiful device that's a
meter long.
It's my fist, ten centimeters in
diameter.
And Bierbaum has flowing through
this a tremendous flow
of helium gas.
And so when you make ions, the
ions are made up here in the
discharge, and then--
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Wha's the
pressure in there?
PROFESSOR ELLISON: The pressure
will be about a torr.
And so it turns out that it's
mostly helium, and you have a
few millitorr of the reagents
that you've got.
You have a quadrupole mass spec.
The quadrupole mass spec, of
course, can't operate in a
millitorr, so there's some
clever pumping that you have
to sample the output of the flow
tube.
So the quadrupole mass spec only
looks at the ions.
So if you have a reaction that
occurs in here, one ion would
go away, and another one would
come up.
And you can monitor this with a
quadrupole mass spec.
Remember, the way the ions get
downstream is they're carried
along by the helium.
And what's true in a flow tube
is, the distance equals the
rate times the time.
So if you have a shorter
distance, you have a shorter
reaction time.
If you have a longer distance,
you have a
longer reaction time.
And if you measure that
variation, you
can get a rate constant.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: How do you
change the distance?
PROFESSOR ELLISON: It turns out
that you can change the
distance by admitting your
reagent through
a tiny little tube.
And this tube is the cutest
little thing you
ever saw in your life.
It slides on a little wire.
And they literally, like a
gorilla, they'll set the
ejection tube at a certain
space, and then what they'll
do, is they'll systematically
vary this by simply
pulling this back.
Then they'll measure the ratios
of these rates.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: We talked
earlier about Robert Hooke
making a vacuum pump
to lower pressure.
So is that the kind, do you have
somebody down,
in the basement pumping on this
or how do you get the vacuum?
PROFESSOR ELLISON: No, it turns
out--
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: That's a lot
of helium you're
putting through.
PROFESSOR ELLISON: Sure.
OK.
So Professor Bierbaum
uses a set of pumps which
are as big as I am.
They're roots blowers.
These pumps will pump just a
staggering quantity of gas,
like 500 liters a second, at
this pressure.
These pumps--
I'm just telling you words--
one of the uses of these pumps
are to pump grain in grain
elevators in Kansas.
Have you ever been to some
dreadful place like Kansas?
I mean, there's 10,000 of these
silos.
And so the grain is pumped
around in these, with these
huge pumps.
So she has two of these in the
basement.
So it's a very hard experiment
to do.
So you can also do radicals in
this.
And let me just tell you
Gutman's experiment.
He's going to measure Kequi
and so he's going to measure the
reaction, from the
equilibrium constant. From the
temperature variation of the
equilibrium constant, he's going
to get the reaction
energy of this.
And the reaction energy of this
radical reaction is,
you're going to have to pay the
bond energy, this CH bond
energy, and you're going to get
the bond
energy of HCI back.
I now have to tell you
something.
The bond energy of HCl is known
to be 103 kcal per mole.
Remember, I told you the bond
energy for methanol is 104.
So the chloride atoms, if they
hit the hydrogen on the OH
group, if they hit it, they'll
just bounce off, because they
don't have enough energy to do
this.
So they're only going to pull
the hydrogens
off the methyl group.
So when you do that, if you do
the analysis, you can get that
the CH bond on methanol is 96
kcal per mole.
And on the days when it works,
you can
get this very precisely.
So those are two of the bond
energies that you
can get from methanol.
So you might wonder, what's the
CO bond in methanol?
In other words, you're literally
going to take the
methanol molecule, and you'll
karate-chop it in the center,
and you just want to cut it in
two.
So that means I've got to
measure the energy of the
methyl radicals and the hydroxyl
radicals.
So it turns out, this is a
straightforward thing to do.
Turns out that if you want to
look at this, this bond
energy, to get that heat of
formation...Here, I need to get
methyl radicals.
So to get methyl radicals, you
actually have to measure the
bond energy of methane.
Because that's the bond energy
of methane is the heat of
formation of methyl radicals,
heat of formation of hydrogen,
minus that of methane.
So photoionization mass spec or
reaction kinetics both
measure the bond energy of
methane to be
104.99 kcal per mole.
The bond energy of hydrogen, H
atom, comes from the
dissociation energy of H2.
So there's classical tables.
These guys, Mr. Pedley and his
friends, there's 3,000 of
these bond energies that these
guys anally
have put in this book.
So it turns out that if you have
these guys, you now use
the heat of formation of methyl
radical.
I also need to tell you that the
bond energy of water gives
you the heat of formation of
methyl
radical-- of hydroxyl radical.
So turns out if I know hydroxyl
radical, and I know
methyl radical, then Pedley et
al will give you the heat of
formation of methanol.
So this is the other thing I'm
going to need.
So turns out that this bond
energy is equal to heat of
formation of methyl radical,
plus OH radical,
minus that of methanol.
And so this comes from water,
that comes from bond energy of
methane, dissociation of
methane.
And this is Mr. Pedley.
So that's actually the weakest
bond in the molecule.
The weakest bond in the molecule
is the CO bond.
So you can actually work all of
three of these bonds out by
going through a procedure.
Me and a whole bunch of other
really smart people have
measured a large number of these
molecules, and these are
the bond energies.
There's all sorts of complicated
heats of formation
that you can use.
Let me just talk here at the
end, for the last part of
this, about trying to compare
these things.
Professor McBride is typically
going on like a broken record.
We always try to say, how do you
know what you've done?
Which means to say--
Here.
I'm not kidding you.
It's very easy to make a
mistake.
If you get any of these
calibrations wrong, or any of
these little cycles are done in
an incorrect manner, it's
very easy for you to have an
uncertainty.
Indeed, let me go back.
I need to make one point I
wasn't smart enough to do
where I had this acidity.
Here.
This bond energy that we're
going to measure--
OK, we're going to get this
through a cycle.
And to do this cycle, we have to
do two difficult
experiments.
Bierbaum has to measure the
acidity.
It's a very large number.
That's 380 kcal per mole.
And the electron affinity is
known.
The ionization energy of
hydrogen atoms is known.
But you have to measure the
electron
affinity for this radical.
So this number comes from a
cycle where you're adding and
subtracting large numbers.
And you're smart guys.
You know this.
If you have a number that you're
after, and there's a
cycle that you go through, and
you're taking differences of
large numbers
any fault, any mistake that's
made here, that error is going
to be in this bond energy, or
any error that comes in this
measurement.
There's a famous chemist who's
English, whose name is Colson.
And Colson used to say,
procedure is like weighing a
captain on the ship by weighing
the ship with and
without the captain.
Here.
So you have an aircraft carrier.
OK.
You're a smart guy.
You get a pair of scales.
And you know you have to measure
this aircraft carrier,
the weight of this very
precisely.
And then you put a little guy on
top, and then the weight's
going to change just a titch.
And your measurements have to be
so precise you
can pick this up.
So on the days when it works,
you can really
get these bond energies.
But these are not easy
experiments to do.
Let me talk here about these
bond energies.
We've done several of these
things.
You might guess that if you have
an alcohol--
I did methanol, this is the OH
bond in methanol--
you might hope that the OH bond
in ethanol
would be the same.
And it's exactly the same within
our uncertainty.
If you go to--
this is isopropyl alcohol, this
is t-butyl alcohol.
t-butyl alcohol is a little bit
larger, but you can see,
amongst friends, it's all about
104, 105 kcal per mole.
When you go to measure something
like phenol--
this is an OH bond in phenol,
but this is only
like 86 kcal per mole.
And you go, Christ, what's wrong
here?
Well, this is no regular
alcohol.
Here, I drew this.
If you break the bond in
methanol, you get a hydrogen
atom, and you get methoxy dots.
And the dot is stuck on the
oxygen atom.
But if you pull a proton off
phenol, now that
dot is not on the oxygen.
It's actually delocalized
around.
It interacts with the pi system.
And McBride's probably drawn you
some of these resonance
forms. Or you can talk about the
interaction of this extra
electron with the pi cloud.
This is a catastrophic change.
What this is, like 20 kcal per
mole.
That's a volt.
So it's a lot easier for you to
remove a hydrogen atom from
phenol than it is from any
alcohol.
We've also done a bunch of
peroxides.
Remember, here's hydrogen
peroxide, here's methyl
hydroperoxide, here's ethyl
hydroperoxide.
These, again, look like OH
bonds.
Here.
You're also smart people.
You know that these peroxides
they're very reactive compounds.
The reason my daughter's a
blonde is because of this.
I mean, you can buy a bottle of
this, and only--
Here, let's see
There's a difference between
chemistry and, say, other
subjects, in that these
molecules are real.
When we go to do this... Here.
My daughter would get...
You could buy a bottle of
peroxide in the pharmacy.
It's 5%.
So it's 5% hydrogen peroxide,
and 95% water.
So we have to make a beam of
these things.
So there's clever ways that if
you can have these compounds,
and you can actually distill
them, then you can make 99%
hydrogen peroxide.
The hydrogen peroxide, of
course, is extremely reactive.
Why is it reactive?
It's because the two oxygens are
held together by a single
bond, and you have all these
electrons that are crammed
right on top of each other.
So the bond energy of the O-O
bond is actually quite weak.
So it's a very good oxidizer.
And so turns out, I've
actually...
we had a bottle of about 99%
percent of this stuff.
And I'm talking about this with
my students.
And I'm not very skillful.
And so it turns they maybe had
about half a
milliliter of this.
As long as hydrogen peroxide is
in glass or
plastic, it's fine.
Nothing's going to happen.
You can handle it safely.
But it will oxidize any carbon
that it gets to.
So alas, I dropped it.
And when I dropped it, it
bounced once on the floor, and
then it broke.
And when it broke, when the
glass came down and broke,
it went, fuff!
And there's a big orange spot
around.
And what happened was, all the
dirt and stuff on the floor
was oxidized immediately!
Just gone.
So if you have a solution of--
Here, you think I'm kidding.
You have a 100% solution of
something like this, you take
a little bunny rabbit with the
ears and sort of
lower this thing in--
this thing is just simply torn
to pieces.
Then you pull this thing out,
there's just bones.
I mean, this is tremendously
reactive!
So all of these things, you have
to handle ‘em, and you've
got to get them into your
spectrometer.
But OK.
So when you do this, you see the
OH bonds--
see the dots here on this?
This is 88 kcal per mole.
This is a lot different than
these guys.
And of course, the one that
you're really
interested in is water.
The bond energy for water is
118.
And that goes to OH dot and H
atom.
This is an important number.
And remember, water covers 70%
of the earth's surface.
Here, you're making
a list of what are
the most stable compounds
that God made, it's N2 in
the air.
80% of the air we're breathing
is N2.
N2 has got a triple bond.
It's indestructible.
Very, very stable.
The sand on beaches.
I mean, the silicon dioxide, the
sand, is just like a rock.
I mean, it is a rock.
And then the other thing is
water.
70% of the earth's surface.
And the reason it's so stable
is, if you want to break this
apart to radicals, you've got to
give me 118 kcal per mole.
That's a whopping amount of
energy.
Here.
And so you notice, if you just
replace this with an
ethyl group, OK?
So you make ethanol.
So the bond energy's going to
drop by almost a volt to 104
kcal per mole.
Here.
Imagine you have a swimming
pool.
So it's a swimming pool.
Johnny Depp is talking to
somebody next to
the swimming pool.
Only instead of the swimming
pool, you have
water, you have ethanol.
It's vodka in there.
So Johnny Depp takes a drag on a
cigarette, and as he's
talking to Angelina Jolie, he
flicks the thing over.
And the split second this hits
the pool, there's a flame like
180 meters high.
Because the ethanol ignites!
It burns.
If it's in water, the cigarette
goes out.
So this bond energy-- if it's a
real stable compound, this
has consequences.
OK.
The last thing I'll tell you
is...Here.
These are the bond energies I
just told you for methanol.
This is the OH bond.
This is the CH bond.
The weakest bond is the CO bond.
These are these numbers in kcal
per mole.
It's always interesting.
If you knew what these bond
energies are, what are the
bond energies for the radicals?
So if I reach in and cut a bond
here and I make methoxy dot,
if I make methoxy dot, now the
bond energy for the CH bond--
Here, I can use the meter
stick--
the CH bond, which used to be 96
kcal per mole, drops to 22.
You can see why.
The minute you cut the bond
here, the hydrogen atom
leaves, but this dot couples
with that dot, and you've got
formaldehyde.
Nice, stable compound.
And the CO bond here is about 90
kcal per mole.
This is about the same thing it
is for
the CO bond in methanol.
You go to the other bond, which
is hydroxy methyl.
You go to this species.
Again, if you cut the bond off
the OH bond, you get a dot
here, and the other dot then
combines back here with
formaldehyde.
So now this is 30 kcal per mole,
to be
contrasted with 106.
What's interesting is the CO
bond, which used
to be 92, goes up.
I don't know why, but it does.
And not by a little bit.
This is almost a volt.
So there's all sorts of
interesting patterns you can
have in these bond energies.
And you literally can have...you
can look at that
not only these
alcohols, but all
sorts of alkyl peroxides and a
variety of these things.
OK. Here.
I'm going to finish early,
you can see.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: There'll be
questions.
PROFESSOR ELLISON: So here
there's another thing
I want to show you.
And that is, when you talk about
what a bond strength is,
it turns out that an early way
that people tried to measure
bond strengths would be that
you'd consider a
molecule like methane--
I need my big stick here--
and you take methane, you can
burn it, and you can actually
measure the energy to take this
apart to a carbon atom
and four hydrogens.
So Chupka described to you how
you would measure the energies
of individual carbon atoms. You
can actually work out that
the bond, to break all four
bonds in methane is going to
cost you 497.5 kcal per mole.
Since there's four bonds in
methane, you'd cross yourself,
think of Jesus, and then just
divide by four.
And if you did that, that number
divided by four is 99
kcal per mole.
And so you figure, that must be
sort of the
average bond energy.
If you go through these cycles,
like I just told you,
you can actually measure
individually.
The first bond is 104.99 plus or
minus 0.03 kcal per mole.
And that's the first bond
energy.
That gives you the absolute heat
of formation of a
methyl radical.
You can now take methyl radical
and
measure the second bond.
Notice the bond energy goes up
from 105 to 110.
Then the third one is 101, and
the last one
is 90 kcal per mole.
And these guys give you,
individually, the heats of
formation of all of these
species.
Notice that not a single one of
these bond energies equals
that average.
Here it's close, but the
uncertainties are such that
it's not quite.
And so using these average bond
energies, you've got to
be careful.
The other thing I'll also tell
you, if you actually take the
sum of these numbers and add
them up, it's 397.5. It's
exactly this.
And this is a testament to the
guys who did these
measurements.
These are very hard experiments
to do, and that
means that each one of these
four numbers is right.
Because you know, this thing has
to be right.
The four of these guys have to
add to these things.
So here. If the sum of these
things is this, that means the
first law of thermodynamics
really works.
So this is a very interesting
set of experiments to do.
OK.
So here.
I'm going to give you people--
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Let's have
some questions.
PROFESSOR ELLISON: OK.
So I'm allowed to show my last
little picture, then.
Here.
I'm in Boulder, Colorado, and
we're not as sophisticated as
you people here are in New
Haven.
So this is me.
Carl Lineberger is the captain
of the negative ions.
The smartest guy in the world
about doing negative ion
spectroscopy.
Chuck DePuy here is a Yale PhD,
is a member of the
National Academy of Sciences.
He's an organic chemist in
Boulder.
Eldon Ferguson is the inventor
of the flowing afterglow.
It was at NOAA.
The National Oceanic and
Atmospheric
Administration in Boulder.
This is Steve Leone, who's one
of the most famous chemical
physicists in the United States.
He's now at Berkeley.
He's the head of the Chemical
Dynamics Beamline out there.
Zdenek Herman was a postdoc here
in the 1960s, and he's at
the Academy of Sciences in
Prague.
And this is Roni Bierbaum, who's
the master of negative
ion chemistry.
So I've given you about ten
minutes early, so I'm happy to
answer any questions that you
people may have.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: OK.
Do you have any questions or
comments?
OK, I have one.
So let's go back to your--
how do we get out of here?
PROFESSOR ELLISON: Oh, you hit a
B?
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: But I want
to go back to the beginning.
Let's, for what it's worth--
here we go.
That, hold up that spectrum you
showed that had vibrational
in here.
PROFESSOR ELLISON: That's right.
Yes, there it is.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Now, do
people understand
how this was working?
You put the laser energy in, and
you measure this
difference, right?
PROFESSOR ELLISON: That's right.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: But
sometimes some of the energy
went into vibration
of the molecule.
So the energy that came out was
smaller, to the extent
that vibration actually went
into the molecule.
So here, you say, is when no
vibrational energy goes into
the product.
So that's how you know what the
lowest energy is.
But here's a peak here.
PROFESSOR ELLISON: Right.
So that comes from the fact that
you have a vibrationally
excited negative ion.
The negative ion, instead of
being in its ground
vibrational state, has a little
bit of energy.
And it will actually be in the
CO stretch, is
where this will be.
So if there's energy in the
negative ion, then, to go back
to my diagram--
if you have hot bands, in other
words, if some of the
molecules have vibrational
energy in this, then the
molecules aren't down here, y
equal to zero, but they're
actually populated in higher
states here.
So that means that those
electrons will take less
kinetic energy to get off.
And you can always spot them,
because they'll have a
different frequency.
Here.
You're going to have a set of
frequencies here, which will
be a mode in the neutral
molecule.
This is the methoxy radical, and
this is that of the
negative ion.
And so this is a vibration in
the negative ion.
And they'll be different,
because the electrons are
different in these things.
So you can guess, when you get
to a molecule which gets to be
more complex, like phenoxy
radical--
I talked to you about that--
phenoxy radical has a lot more
atoms. So analyzing this
steadily gets more and more
difficult.
But we like to do that.
That's what God put us on this
earth for.
You can also guess--
I'm interested right now in
sugars, because I'm interested
in how biomass decomposes.
You know what glucose looks
like?
Glucose is a molecule that has
many different hydroxyls on
it, and hydroxyls are all
slightly different.
So now, instead of making a
negative ion like in methoxy--
I mean, how hard can this be?
You've only got one OH.
What happens if you add ethylene
glycol, or if you
take glycerol--
ethylene glycol has two
hydroxyls, glycerol has three,
threose is going to have four,
ribose is going to have five.
So now you're going to have to
begin to tell which
OH this came from.
So this is going to be a bitch.
But you if you can do this, you
would be able to take
these molecules, and you'll be
able to break all the bonds in
the order that you'd like to do
it.
And that's very interesting to
do.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: So you were
very kind to speak about putting
electrons in the sigma star
orbitals.
You don't believe in the sigma*
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE:
Ellison is not a big
fan of molecular orbitals.
I think.
Is that true?
PROFESSOR ELLISON: Yes.
Yes, that is true.
Look, I do valence bond work.
This is a matter of taste.
There's different ways to view
these things.
And in the end, the only thing
that
counts is what you measure.
Here, if you have a
model that can
account for the patterns that
you've measured, and you can
predict what the next values
are going to be, you understand
this.
But it's the data is what
survives.
The rest of it is all a matter
of opinion.
He likes sigma* orbitals, I
don't.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: You were
talking about the stability of
the phenoxy radical, in terms of
its resonant stabilization.
So I think these people could
help you out with that.
Or at least point out something
interesting
Would you say that this radical
is stable because you
can draw resonance
structures that have
the electrons over here.
PROFESSOR ELLISON: Yes, that's
right.
Correct.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: But how
about if you say that
in the starting
phenol, that's the bond that
you're going to
break in here, right?
Here I've got a pair of
electrons that I can draw
resonance structures for.
So it looks to me like it's
worth more
here than it is here.
PROFESSOR ELLISON: Listen, dream
on, big boy.
Look--
Here, how do I push this thing
up?
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: OK, we'll
get that.
PROFESSOR ELLISON: Here.
So this electron is going to get
delocalized
over the whole molecule.
If you try to do this with an
electron pair, what you're
going to have is--
OK.
So if I do that, I'm pushing
charges around.
Well, I don't like that.
I don't like the fact that the
oxygen is going to have--
you're starting to suck
electrons--
if the electrons migrate down,
the oxygen is going to become
positively charged.
So jeez, I just would never do
that.
But here.
But what's true is that bond
energy, honest to God, really
and truly, is 86 kcal per mole.
That is a fact.
And this is a flippant way to
have anticipated this.
Contrast that with, say, methoxy
dot-- where's that
electron going to go?
It's really stapled to the
oxygen atom.
There's nothing it can do.
It can't go anywhere.
So when you break that bond, you
get hydrogen atom.
You get the dot that's just
stuck right there.
As you pull this bond off, the
dot now is able to be
delocalized and spread around
the whole ring, and this bond
energy, then, in phenol, this
bond energy that's going to be
86 kcal per mole--
this thing lets you measure the
absolute heat of formation
298 of this thing.
This low bond energy is going to
mean that this heat of
formation is going to be low.
So what that means is, if we're
trying to study lignin,
and lignin are trees--
you take a chainsaw and you're
cutting trees down, that's
very tough material.
All these compounds are long,
three-dimensional polymers of
aryl alkyl ethers.
So if you know the heat of
formation of the phenoxy
radical, this bond turns out to
be 62 kcal per mole.
And if you do this in this, it's
like 90.
And that's a volt and a half.
So when you heat this, all these
molecules break apart, and the
first thing they do is they form
phenoxy radicals.
And this triggers the
decomposition of these things.
So it turns out, I don't like
these things in the neutral
molecule being delocalized.
Because I think you have to
separate charge, and
I don't like that.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: There are
actually people back there who
are smart at this kind of stuff.
Do you guys buy that?
PROFESSOR ELLISON: You?
STUDENT: What I'm thinking is,
if you have that kind of
species, you'd think there'd be
a spin observable.
PROFESSOR ELLISON: Oh, indeed
there is.
If you look at the EPR spectrum
of this radical, it
is delocalized all over the
place.
And here, you're an expert in
this.
You know about all these
hyperfine
couplings and whatnot.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Yes, there's
coupling
from the protons around here.
It's like NMR. So if the
electron spin gets out on
these protons, then it interacts
with the nucleus, even
if the molecule's tumbling, you
don't have to worry about
the anisotropy.
So it's no doubt it gets
delocalized, but why
doesn't this one?
So Barney says it's because he
doesn't like to separate
charge in resonance structures.
But that's not-- is this
Coulomb's law, or what?
Anybody got an idea back there?
PROFESSOR ELLISON: Well, here.
What do you mean, is this
Coulomb's law?
Coulomb's law is what it is.
So here.
If resonance forms like this are
important, then that means
that I think, as a consequence
of this, you have to have
charge separation.
And I think these are
high-energy resonance forms.
And if they're high-energy
resonance forms, they don't
contribute to the superposition
in the wave
function, is the way I say that.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: That's
because you
believe in resonance.
G.BARNEY ELLISON: Because I'm a
valence-bond guy. But what's
true is this 86 kcal per mole.
Nothing can be done about that.
OK.
00:47:27,533 --> 00:00:00,000
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: OK. I think
we can thank Professor Ellison.